so at the end of our little thing here
that we do um YouTube is is that we do a
thing called unhelpful advice and you
know we you know people email us and we
try to give them you know I love the
helpful unhealthy I want to steal that
debt you do whatever you want can I
steal that yeah well we have voicemails
where people call in and leave a
voicemail we and we play it but we get I
feel like we want to do that we don't we
just call people because you call people
I've never pick up okay so that's what I
think I feel like whenever we take wife
calls it's kind of always a disasters it
was like hey what's your favorite color
yeah he just leaves voicemails for
people interested I mean now are you
which if like a network like would you
be a talk show host do you think or now
like we've actually been having the
opportunity to make our own show yeah
but we passed why because I think that
we are probably better off like managing
ourselves well we felt unready to I know
and honestly I'm not I'm not a good
writer I'm not I think I it was scary
was Carrie know what you would have a
staff correct yes right so you would
come in and go I'm good at like people
throwing me ideas I don't know yeah I
like that yeah I mean yeah so I'm not
dumb I know what would what my muscles
are in comedy I'm not that much of a
writer either I mean I have written
things before but um I would have you
know three or four really funny you know
creative guys and this but the thing is
is that I should think more like you do
and the way I think about it because the
thing is is that a lot of times I go out
you know I'll go to a comedy club or
I'll even go to a cafe or wherever it
might be and people will walk up and go
tiger belly and they'd say nosotros
papaya or things I say on the thing or
you know know that George is a pink dick
that's a
and then we do yeah and or like beating
it yes you've all seen it yes what was
that tasteful no because I don't want to
see you
one of those jumping in the beach photos
fell out it was a show yeah yeah but the
thing is is that I should look great
look at what dances good yeah you look
at your show h3 as the actual thing
right it's the thing like I've arrived
this is no I don't feel that I'm so
confused about what I do if I'm being
honest I I'm perpetually unhappy and
unsatisfied with it it's so funny
because a couple days ago I get a call
from Chris D'Elia hmm and Chris goes on
should I do this h3 thing I go it's
[ __ ] amazing
that's all thank you oh you're not done
no no we're done I didn't not doing it
for you yeah yeah it helps him yeah
right
but D'Elia was like I'm gonna do it has
he done it yet no no we just coming up
right yeah but he's gonna do it right
yeah yeah but my point is is that so you
it's already your if you're getting
people to go I'm gonna do it I want to
do it
tell me about them and I'm getting those
calls then you've already
it's a you're already a thing that's
really exciting it is
you're a [ __ ] thing all right now
that's great to hear but what I have to
say is I have to say what I'm trying to
twist it is I have to realize that Tiger
belly is also a thing yeah definitely
and I'm always going how do I get the
next thing right I do that too so
annoying but I get it snowing but I
should already go I already have the
thing it's like self thought you can't
you can't listen here like we can't let
ourselves be happy yeah it's always like
that oh this is great but this is
already like not good enough it's always
like they say who's they it's a
proverbial kind of thought that you know
the people who are always not
satisfied are the ones that are always
pushing to higher ground right I come
for myself with that because I'm always
dissatisfied yeah
maybe there's a level of like this
content but it's pretty good and healthy
but you've gotta be you gotta have a
little bit a little satisfy okay you
know what that was that went well I was
happy with that or else yeah no I feel
the same way III swear to god I'm
[ __ ] I'm very depressed and miserable
person
I do think I think at least you guys
have bought two barbecues we don't even
do that
it's we just sit in our home we don't
party that much now look out there
flipping burgers every day it's like I
only all I ever wanted was you're right
I would been telling Co Lila like why
can't I get on a show I got on a show it
gets picked up for a second season and
people go hey congratulations ago ah
yeah but you know I'm fifth lead or like
I just say some sort of [ __ ]
negative thing yeah and it's like it's
something that I've always wanted to do
but there's no dumb when I hate that
about human nature and about me when you
become the guy that's like I'm so
[ __ ] stoked I got this job there's
something very unfunny about that right
more like spiritually balance or
actualized [ __ ] funny never it's it
almost seems so weird to me that I don't
trust them like kids in their basement
exactly
oh you're satisfied with your job tell
me about what's in your basement yeah
[Applause]
I have a friend she always talks about
like past life regressions and being
like being a some type of spiritual
leader and she does like hypnotizes
people and she seems so like seemingly
balanced and perfect not only is she not
funny but if you met her in real life
he's a [ __ ] nutcase like you just
feel you're like dude just stamped three
feet away from me like you know don't
point a knife in my direction just scary
but is there is your balance
yeah there's some there's a there's a
rare breed of I have some people who I
know that our that do enjoy balance in
their life but it's I have to tell you I
think it's rare cuz I have a lot of
friends in show biz and I was just
talking with them last week they're all
[ __ ] miserable
it's never gonna end is basically worse
I didn't know why Macaulay Culkin got
out he had that whole career now he's
going oh he's back he just did Allen no
show no no oh is he
he was actually people brothers out
there no he just did Ellen he just did
Kimmel he is because he's promoting his
podcast oh yeah oh you guys go on Kimmel
to promote help I feel like Kim o like
who are you talking to you know what I
mean people are podcast but no they're
not that's another and how stressful is
it to be on Kimmel I think it's
equivalent exchange you know i mean i
i'd almost pass on that cuz i'd be too
stressed yeah but here's another
interesting thing that you just have
that I wanted to end but we can't break
the record with you guys I'm not gonna
break the right what's the record it's
not that over our 30 can accurate record
yeah yeah so what I'm saying is he won't
give that to you Howard Hughes never
shut ultimate thing that you just did
well we're gonna do this though you know
I'm not gonna even say whatever
he's not gonna win
yeah well I was gonna say that is this
is that it's so funny that you said that
because there is a different group of
people
I'll give you an example um I get Tiger
belly ten times a day
I get mad tv you know five times a day
zero times have I gotten splitting up
together that's it come to gut done
right and I go around no one's ever said
anything I love the show yeah I love you
on that right never right and so what
I'm saying is is I know I look at the
numbers and you know we got our opening
weekend we got eight million viewers
that's a hell of a lot of people but
these are people never seen what is it
you know what that's what kind of
frustrates me about what we do is
because when we talk about something or
have someone on the people really
respond yeah it's a different vibe what
do you mean exactly what I mean I guess
is that the connection with our audience
is way more direct and way more profound
yes so if somebody comes on to promote
something I think they'll get way more
out of it than Jimmy Kimmel with five
million people million with us is worth
I think way more than five million with
Jimmy Kimmel and it's frustrating that
people don't understand that because a
lot of people are like who the [ __ ] like
oh ha you know what I mean they they
snub it's so funny because my numbers on
the road I can see it the ticket sales
because I do live shows right and when
we started this and I started doing h3
on these other one other things that him
um I tripled the amount of welcome to my
shows I sell out now that's before by
doing all the other stuff to zero that's
great okay so what am I saying it
through like it's in true nobody
watching Jimmy Kimmel gives a [ __ ] I
don't know why it is but people are
sitting at their computer they're
listening they're connected mm-hmm but
it's evil on Jimmy Kimmel are sitting
there with the five five in their bed at
the remote and their guard listen are
stuffed people to choose to watch and
something like Jimmy Kimmel you don't
really [ __ ]
boy nobody wants to wants to watch she's
like mo it's what's on there it's just
there that's a great life from Seinfeld
they go they said when they're pitching
the show they say why would anyone watch
this and George goes because it's on TV
what Rodney King said Bob each other
forever
okay but in when you said that's
interesting so what I'm saying is is
that so at the end of the day and let me
just close it all up by saying okay what
time is it no more man the question is
yeah I know it's gonna be a question oh
no way I want to talk
[Music]